yes William we were about eight feet
away from where it happens we saw it all
happen and I'm just really thankful that
it really hadn't left two minutes
earlier oh my goodness me I mean you
must be I suspect on the on the verge if
not in a state of shock could you bear
to share with us what you saw yes I'm
running on adrenaline at the moment so
everything's coming out quite fast so we
arrived at lunchtime today I've never
been to Berlin before first a holiday
and we decided to wander down to the
Christmas market and partake in some of
the mulled wine and what why else was on
offer we sat and we were drinking and
very luckily I broke my leg a few years
ago and have to sit down for a lot
longer than I would normally my friend
said let's go and I said we'll give me
two minutes and then we heard a really
loud bang and saw some of the Christmas
lights to our left starting to be pulled
down and then we saw the articulated
vehicle going through people and through
the stall and just pulling everything
down and then everything went dark so it
was very difficult to be there goodness
me and in that and in the confusion ma
do you know what happened to you in the
sense that how you avoided that truck or
was it just all a blur so we were very
very lucky in that we had gone into the
light there's like little booths around
the stalls where you can go to stretch
and we've gone up a couple of stairs to
go and sit in one of those but had we
been down the stair stood next to the
stall we probably would have been caught
up in it did you see people running did
you did you hear people shouting yes
there was lots of there was lots of
screaming there were lots of people
yelling so the stall that we felt for
emerald wine from was come
lately crushed and there are people
tearing off the wooden panels to get the
people out luckily everyone in there was
pulled out but as we walked we just
wanted to get back to the hotel as
quickly as possible and we just didn't
want to stay because we didn't know if
something else was going to happen or or
whether we were we just didn't know we
just didn't know and we saw people and
we just had to kind of steal our eyes
and just walk through and I wanted to
stop and help but we just wanted to make
sure that we were safe firstly
absolutely did you see the truck come to
a halt no it was still going at a speed
when it passed us and I the first thing
I did was call my mum I just got my
phone out and because I knew it would be
all over the news and I just had to
really call her so it didn't see it come
to a start because my first thought was
obviously for myself really selfishly
but it was something that needed to be
to be done how long ago did it happen
and we've been back here about 45
minutes an hour well you definitely need
to I don't know what the situation is I
mean there were we do know what the
situation is we can see how confused it
all isn't it obviously the immediate
concerns are for those that have been
physically in the attack but thank you
very much indeed for talking to us just
just one last question about this Emma
if you can bear it and do tell me if you
don't want to talk to us anymore because
I fully understand what you've been
through in the in the situation that you
must be in but did you get a sense of
that of a speed that this was traveling
out of the fact that it looked like it
was a deliberate act it wasn't an
accident it when it was going 40 miles
an hour it was the middle of the market
there is there are two main roads either
side of a square which is the market
this was the middle of the market there
is no way that it could have come off
the road and it showed no sign
slowing down whether it was there any
sign while you were there before it
happened of increased security of any
security around the market no I mean it
was just a normal Christmas market
something that you may go through in
London or or Birmingham it was just a
really festive evening with lots of
Christmas music Christmas lights we were
taking photographs it was jolly and
that's what makes it more terrifying is
that something like this can happen
smack bang in the middle of you know a
tourist Christmas holiday was it packed
sorry am I not sure you heard me were
there a lot of people there there were a
lot of people there were lots of lots of
people you know this is Monday evening
people have finished work there are
tourists there he will have flown in
today he would have been here a couple
of days we actually passed some UK
tourists as we were walking back to our
hotel and heard them saying they were
going to the Christmas market so we
stopped them and said please don't go
this is what happens call your families
tell them that you're safe so there were
lots and lots of people there did you
see as you were you were leaving and as
you described to us some you were quite
rightly concerned for your own safety
did you see emergency services did you
see police ambulances and others start
to arrive please please were there very
very quickly the first ambulances hadn't
arrived by the time we were looking to
leave but we were you know we were in
the city bit as it happened we walked
past very injured people but yeah the
police were there very quickly and but
we're on the street where our hotel is
on the street by the Christmas market is
so we've been hearing emergency services
up and down a street over the past hour
and there any sense of what you're going
to do now or haven't you really managed
to - let it all sink in to get your
thoughts together I think running on
adrenaline at the moment and I don't
think I'll be going to sleep anytime
soon but the thing is you know we can't
say for definite whether this was
deliberate or I mean
look certainly looks like it from our
point of view but you never know but
whatever happens if it wants to live but
we can't let that ruin and everything
else so I think that at some point we
will go out tomorrow and we will carry
on because that's what we have to do to
make sure that people who do do things
like this deliberately don't Lee